That's will happen. The Joe
Rogan experience. So you're
there every Wednesday,
every Wednesday night. And that's when
the gym is pretty packed and whizzy nice.
We do a live workout and people come,
you take people through this workout.
Oh yeah. If they, if they
come on Wednesday nights, I've
trained people, you know, I,
I it, it's on Wednesday nights.
Absolutely free. I'll see. That's known.
You don't make them. I have people
come over on Wednesday nights.
They trained for absolutely free.
All you gotta do is sign the waiver.
So if you get fucked up, it's on you. You
don't try to assume me in it like that.
But if you come on a Wednesday night
and sign the waiver is absolutely free.
That's amazing. Yeah. I
yell and scream at them.
Let me see to call me a
mother fucking people.
It's so funny. They, my
mother fucking, I'm like,
I've been calling people a motherfucker,
you know,
since the fifth grade for for nothing
man. He wasn't that weird. Yeah.
And now they want me to
call him a motherfucker. You
know, I'm, I'm on, uh, uh,
cameo,
cameo and on the cameo they can for
25 bucks out a customer out. Oh,
that's how the APP
application became your app.
And a 25 bucks. I cussed him out
and I'm like, damn, I used to cuss.
We probably for nothing.
That's how many [inaudible] do I do?
About 10 a day. Really? Yeah.
Wow. I'm out, man. Wish,
wish my, uh, you know,
wished me happy fucking birthday ECT and
I wish them happy birthday or whatever
the fuck they want. Five bucks, man.
That's very reasonable. Yeah. Yeah.
Used to be more and, and a,
and I said, Nah, fuck it.
And make it cheaper so more people
can afford to do it. I don't mind. Oh,
my cousin.